you are now
the cto of uh
tens torrent as of two months ago
they uh build hardware for deep learning
how do you build scalable and efficient
deep learning this is such a fascinating
space yeah yeah so it's interesting so
um
up until recently i thought there was
two kinds of computers there are serial
computers
that run like c programs and then
there's parallel computers so the way i
think about it is you know parallel
computers you have given parallelism
like gpus are great because you have a
million pixels and modern gpus run a
program on every pixel
they call the shader program right so or
like finite element analysis you you
build something you know you make this
into little tiny chunks you give each
chunk to a computer
so you're given all these chunks you
have parallel something like that
but most c programs you write this
linear narrative
and you have to make it go fast to make
it go fast you predict all the branches
all the data fetches and you run that
more in parallel but that's found
parallelism
ai is i'm still trying to decide how
fundamental this is
it's a given parallelism problem but the
way people
describe the neural networks and then
how they write them in pi torch it makes
graphs yeah
that might be fundamentally different
than the gpu kind of parallelism yeah it
might be
because the when you run the gpu program
on all the pixels
you're running like you know depends you
know this group of pixels say it's
background blue and it runs a really
simple program this pixel is
you know some patch of your face so you
have some really interesting shader
program to give you impression of
translucency
but the pixels themselves don't talk to
each other there's no graph
right so you you do the image and then
you do the next image and you do the
next image
and you run 8 million pixels 8 million
programs every time and modern gpus have
like 6 000
thread engines in them so you know to
get 8 million pixels each one runs a
program on you know 10 or 20
pixels and that's how that's how they
work but there's no graph
but you think graph might be a totally a
new way to think about hardware so raja
gadori and i've been having this
conversation about given versus found
parallelism
and then the kind of walk because we got
more transistors like
you know computers way back when did
stuff on scalar data
then we did it on vector data famous
vector machines now we're making
computers that operate on matrices
right and then the the category we we
said that was next was spatial
like imagine you have so much data that
you know you want to do the compute on
this data
and then when it's done it says send the
result to this pile
of data run some software on that and
it's better to
to think about it spatially than to move
all the data to a central processor and
do all the work
so especially i mean moving in the space
of data as opposed to moving the data
yeah you have a you have a petabyte data
space spread across some huge array of
computers
and when you do a computation somewhere
you send the result of that computation
or maybe
a pointer to the next program to some
other piece of data and do it
but i think a better word might be graph
and all the ai neural networks are
graphs
do some computations then the result
here do another computation do a data
transformation do a merging do a pooling
do another computation is it possible to
compress and say how we make this thing
efficient this whole process efficient
is different
so first the fundamental elements in the
graphs are things like matrix multiplies
convolutions
data manipulations and data movements so
gpus emulate those things with their
little singles
you know basically running a single
threaded program
and then there's a you know nvidia calls
it a warp where they group a bunch of
programs that are similar together
so for efficiency and instruction use
and then at a higher level you kind of
you take this graph and you say this
part of the graph is the matrix
multiplier which runs on these
32 threads but the model
at the bottom was built for running
programs on pixels not
executing graphs so it's emulation yes
so is it possible to build something
that natively runs graphs
yes so that's what 10 story did
so where are we on that how like in the
history of that effort
are we in the early days yeah i think so
tense torrance
started by a friend of mine labija bajak
and i
i was his first investor so i've been
you know kind of
following him and talking to him about
it for years and
in the fall when i was considering
things to do
i decided you know the we we held a
conference last year with a friend
organized it and
and we we wanted to bring in thinkers
and two of the people were andre
carpassi
and chris ladner and andre gave this
talk
on youtube called software 2.0 which i
think is great
which is we went from programmed
computers
where you write programs to data program
computers
you know like the futures you know of
software as data programs the the
networks
and i think that's true and then
chris has been work he worked on llvm
the low-level virtual machine which
became the intermediate representation
for all compilers
and now he's working on another project
called mlir which is mid-level
intermediate representation which is
essentially under the graph about how do
you represent that kind of computation
and then coordinate large numbers of
potentially heterogeneous computers
and i would say technically tense
torrents
you know two pillars are those those
those two ideas software 2.0 and
mid-level representation
but it's in service of executing graph
programs
the hardware is designed to do that so
it's including the hardware
piece yeah and then the other cool thing
is
for a relatively small amount of money
they did a test chip and two production
chips
so it's like a super effective team and
and unlike some ai startups where if you
don't build the hardware to run the
software that they really want to do
then you have to fix it by writing lots
more software
so the hardware naturally does matrix
multiply convolution the data
manipulations
and the data movement between processing
elements that
that you can see in the graph which i
think is all pretty clever
and that's that's what i'm
i'm working on now
you